encore faire je peux vous demander un
truc très tentant de parler
vous êtes contents que je sois là
évidemment quelle question
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a eues ici
tient même à travers sa voix était
rassuré sa part commencé ce moment là et
vous préférez laurent caraux ou moi ce
fut mieux la fin vous aime tous les
trois vous êtes nos enfants abandonnés
quand je commence à m'impatienter
lacarrau il avait un verre non c'est
beaucoup mais point il est ou alors un
peu chercher la mère s'appelait dû
combler d'autres en baisse c'est vrai
que j'ai pas être changé la barre francs
non mais c'est parce que j'ai couru pour
préparer mon voyage
ah oui d'accord bon appétit
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est pas très
frais
une maman a trois enfants et deux pommes
c'est riche interdite comment fait-elle
pour donner la même chose à chaque
enfant tu aurais tu sens en punir un
tout à ces partis c'est moi je l'inventé
c'est une devinette super donc pas
savoir pourquoi les moyens de changer de
sujet c'est juste une devinette avec des
pommes